son retour en méditerranée orientale
promettait une nouvelle désescalade
entre la turquie et la grèce et le bras
de fer continue
aujourd'hui le président turc riposte et
assure qu'il donnera à la grèce
la réponse qu'elle mérite nous allons
continuer d'apporter à la grèce c'est à
l'administration chypriote grecque qui
ne respectent pas leurs engagements sur
les plates formes de l'union européenne
et de l'otan
la réponse qu'elle mérite sur le terrain
dimanche soir en quarts a annoncé le
déploiement de laurie crise dans une
zone de la méditerranée orientale que se
disputent la grèce et la turquie pour
une mission de sondages sismiques
l'emploi et la destination du navire
d'exportation sont un sujet de discorde
entre les deux pays depuis déjà
plusieurs mois
escorté par des bâtiments de guerre il
avait mené en août des recherches dans
les eaux territoriales grecques
revendiquée par la turquie à la
recherche de gaz naturel
de son côté la grèce revendique sa
souveraineté sur ses espaces maritimes
et ankara souhaite des droits plus
étendus en méditerranée orientale en
raison de son littoral plus long un
nouvel affront que la grèce ne digère
pas le pays a annoncé mardi qu'il ne
prendra part à aucun des pourparlers
tant que l'orque reis et ses navires
d'escort seront sur place
une joute navale au centre de toutes les
attentions après l'annnonce du nouveau
déploiement de leur crise les états unis
et l'allemagne ont exhorté mardi la
turquie à mettre fin aux provocations
nous sommes extrêmement consternée par
le fait qu'à cause de nouvelles
provocations
ce processus de discussions ces
négociations directes que nous
considérons toujours comme la bonne
façon de résoudre les problèmes soient
devenus plus difficiles mais ankara a
balayé les critiques jugeant qu'elle
n'avait aucune valeur ce jeudi à la
demande d'athènes
la question sera d'ailleurs à l'ordre du
jour à l'occasion d'une réunion du
conseil européen